This episode is sponsored by state form.
Star Wars was ruined forever.
Thanks to the monsters at Disney star Wars will be on.
Ruined by an all new streaming series.
Made by the monsters at Disney. I'm confused. Do they hate us or not?
This is the way the Mandalorian
anagen was supposed to bring balance.
Luke should have saved the day and Ray just ended up squatting at the form of
her mentors, uncle that he hated. And couldn't wait to run away from, sorry.
Sorry, not today. Episode nine. Now as our heroes fall,
one food truck enthusiast will rise.
Revitalize the franchise in his VR garage and keep the empire in business.
With eight episodes of Western riffs,
they got the fan base all up in their feelings over a Muppet baby,
Kathleen Kennedy, more like Craply and kina all
suit up with within Jorin AKA Mondo, which starts to sound like a slur.
The more you hear it.
Hey man, don't hand over the child. Amanda, get that plastic.
Uh, guys, that's their word? Are you sure we can use it? Uh, truth.
The motto after the prequels literally ruined his childhood.
Follow this wandering bounty Hunter on a tale of redemption in between a whole
bunch of actual wandery.
As he jets from exotic locales to less exotic locales to a
quick detour, to most nostalgia, to pick up a delivery of Easter eggs,
womp rack.
Tusken Raiders.
But screw it. How fun is it to dig around in the star Wars universe?
Without some sad kid in there, daddy has used killing the vibe, man.
Everything will change when this loan not a gun gun gunman,
maybe he's a Gungan meets the most adorable MacGuffin of all time,
the child, okay. You know what? We're not doing that. He's the baby Yoda.
We're calling him baby Yoda.
He's a magic puppet who can kill you with [inaudible].
And if that doesn't.
Work, he can always just kill you.
But one thing is for certain he's not nearly as precocious when they reveal
he's actually a middle age, man. They said 50 years old.
I'm only you baby Yoda. You can talk.
You're just some creepy boomer with a diaper fetish. Aren't you Emily,
but let my kid play with you. Saddle up for brand new star Wars adventures.
The likes of which you've never seen before, but don't freak out.
Look the moodier stuff tattooing let's say stormtroopers, good breathe.
Good.
In this tale of one man's destiny to clear and extremely low bar
be the best single dad in star Wars.
But this father son duo won't travel alone.
There's Quiel who finally gave a modern update to talk to the hand.
I have spoken. I have spoken.
Welcome to buy as few gaze acting coach. You take this home.
Throw it in a pot, add some broth, a potato [inaudible].
And Kara dune the ex rebel with less range than the guy in the helmet.
So we're going to build a trap.
We're going to need to take real deep right here so that when it steps in,
it drops together. They'll encounter scum, villainy,
and the best alternate dimension cast of Saturday night live with
Horatio's.
Sam's Brian [inaudible] Amy Sedaris,
bill bird,
Richard [inaudible] Jason's at aqueous,
Andrew host Tyco YTD.
If suffered damage to your central processing unit,
you mean my brain. That was a joke.
So strap in for a show that every level of star Wars fan can enjoy.
Whether you're a new who just wanted to know why baby Yoda was on your kid's
Christmas list, but stuck around. Cause it reminded you of the searchers,
a casual fan who spent eight episodes wondering why Luke Skywalker wasn't in the
Boba Fett show or a hardcore nerd who needed validation for keeping your toy
collection, mint and box all these years. Wait,
is that the Imperial troop transport of my youth.
It's it's beautiful that owes its success to telling a simple lean
story about an all new family in the star Wars universe.
And because it was a hit,
they're probably about to weigh it down with a bunch of lower crossovers.
And spin-offs ah, this is the way
starring dark helmet. Ah, I'm 50 baby.
You've got a root lease do going MMA.
[inaudible] Warner Herzog as himself.
I see nothing but deaths and chaos.
I would like to see the baby. Yes. Aiden, I'm sorry, sir.
You sounded like someone else. The babysitter clubs,
you don't pity then shut your mouth because I have spoken
the outer sky rib. How do you like the Maddox? Huh? Bobo feet.
Let's make the baby and do the magic hands. Come on baby.
Do the magic hand thing.
That's not how the magic hand thing works nerds of the round table.
And when my friends ask what fastball song we're listening to,
this is the way this is the way this is the way, right?
That's just the way this is the way this is the way this is the way.
The outer rim job.
And once again, the galaxy has a mostly mechanic,
bounty hunting and Cantina centric economy.
No one's ever a real estate agent in these things, marketing.
Some of the star Wars universe remains dentist free don't they have teeth.
Do you know your ID? Eleven's from your K2 SOS.
Then you should play our star Wars edition of the fandom by the trivia game
where you can win up to $650.
Click the box or the link in the description below this episode is sponsored by
state farm, like a good neighbor state farm is there.
I am a Mandalorian. Weapons are part of my religion.
This is the way or I have spoken I'm curvy.
And I like it.